bonjour
Cécile François Gomet je suis dirigeante
de la cabane de Grimm et artisan
chocolatier glacier que je vous propose
là c'est de vous présenter le montage
d'une bûche phare que l'on a cette année
qui est la bûche Galaxy puisque toutes
nos pièces tournent autour du thème un
Noël dans l'espace cette année
je vous propose de monter cette bûche on
va commencer par turbiner le sorbet
ananas j'ai déjà préparé à l'avance un
insert sorbet mangue passion que je vais
recouvrir de chocolat c'est parti on va
mixer émulsionner la glace avant de la
mettre en turbine voilà ça permet de
bien lier les éléments entre eux pour
avoir une glace la plus onctueuse
possible et on va verser ça dans la
turbine
voilà et on en a pour une petite
vingtaine de minutes
[Musique]
alors là maintenant ce qu'on va faire
c'est
préparer le l'enrobage de notre bûche
[Musique]
alors là on va sortir la glace de la
turbine
[Musique]
je récupère mon insert
faites le montage d'une bûche se fait à
l'envers
[Musique]
alors là nous allons démouler notre
bûche maintenant qu'elle a bien refroidi
[Musique]
bah voilà je nous avons réalisé ensemble
la bûche Galaxy je vous souhaite de
bonnes fêtes de fin d'année
[Musique]